il est loin le temps où yvan colonna se
montrer devant les caméras
nationaliste convaincu puis membre du
flnc il a à peine 20 ans et des
convictions bien établie nous on veut
l'autodétermination du peuple cours
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que le
peuple corse ne soit plus en sus en
situation coloniale à tous les niveaux
si le peuple corse qui sera son choix
vingt ans plus tard il est devenu
l'homme le plus recherché de france et
depuis quatre ans les policiers n'ont
pas une piste sérieuse pour le localiser
il y a deux mois une énième berck
édition cette fois ci au domicile de ses
parents n'a rien donné depuis qu'il a
quitté sa bergerie le 23 mai 99 yvan
colonna a été vu partout même au
venezuela mais pour beaucoup de corses
il n'a pas dû aller bien loin se cacher
dans le maquis est une pratique bien
rodé on ne prend pas de maquis dans le
maquis justement on et ont peut être
reçu dans un village par des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément vos idées politiques
ou visiter tout simplement simplement
parce que les lois de l'hospitalité
en cavale le fugitif ne s'est manifestée
qu'une seule fois c'était il ya deux ans
dans une lettre il clamait son innocence
comment peut-il échapper aux policiers
l'omerta les réseaux sont depuis
toujours une aide précieuse je pense que
yvan colonna bénéficie du soutien de
ceux qu'on appelle les indépendantistes
les gouvernements qui se sont succédé
ont tous connu l'échec à son arrivée
nicolas sarkozy a décidé de doubler le
nombre d'enquêteurs et de leur fournir
du matériel de contre espionnage
pour la veuve de l'ancien préfet
l'absence d' yvan colonna devient pesant
tu
maintenant il faudrait vraiment arrêter
l'assassin présumé de mon mari et je
pense qu'après voilà ça a toujours été
mon combat et
je pense qu'à ce moment là je pourrais
être tranquille si le berger de cargèse
été retrouvé il serait jugé seul son cas
en effet été disjoint de celui des
autres membres du commando
[Musique]